we're in the middle of our small
business challenge where two
entrepreneurs compete to win a prize
package
which includes ten thousand dollars
and joining me is the incredible code
judge i can't believe it it's damon
johnson
thank you um okay before the break
justin and jasmine pitch their
businesses morning joyco
um and now it's time for our next
entrepreneur to make her case please say
hello to
tamara walker the owner of queen bee
jelly tamara
what is your pitch and why should you
win so with queen bee jelly
you know have you ever gone through work
and just like i can't do this anymore
i'm so over this
well if not i did um i was headed up the
escalators i just got off the train in
washington dc
into an amazing law firm and i said this
can't be life there has to be more to it
and so i've always been a fan of
clothing but i knew that there was more
to it
i had to really understand like but what
is it about clothes you know we
all love to look good but it was more
along the lines of
the textures and prints and all that
beauty of fabric
so um that's when i realized i wanted to
open queen bee jelly modern fabrics
and um with creamy jelly we specialize
in
um ankara and ankara is this beautiful
fabric
that is originally created in holland
it's a big staple
in the african community i want people
to feel
excited when they see this fabric i want
them to
be inspired and that's the whole beauty
of queen bee jelly
is for folks to see the fabric and just
be inspired
thank you so much tamara damon what is
your question so i think it's beautiful
fabrics um how are you selling it now is
it people buying it for
them to make dresses or is it for
curtains drapes
bedding or all of it actually folks are
buying it for apparel for clothing and
also for upholstery you can use it
for your drapes for your chairs your
couches
all of the above what are your sales um
so i have a total
of um monthly it can be about
50 50 times um
at least 200 sales okay excellent
excellent
i fell in love with your fabrics i think
they are so artistic
um when i'm like just
pitching an idea to a walmart or
whatever businesses i'm working with
a lot of the times i'll hear what's the
google search
and it's a big thing that people really
care about in business and when i was
google searching your business
i had a little trouble with the queen
bee jelly and i think
if there's a way to bring in that modern
fabrics to the forefront
you'll be quicker to find because once i
got to your social which i know you're
not the biggest fan of social but your
social is really good
um so i just want to make sure that
modern fabrics is in there to set you
apart because queen bee jelly
and i understood all the meaning behind
it
i i wanted to to see that modern fabrics
in there as much as possible you
probably need fabric modern fabrics by
queen bee jelly because queen bee jelly
all three of those words are very common
words and that's why you try to create
companies named the fubu
or google or nike words that don't
necessarily exist
because then you'll have problems google
searching it or trademarking it
in various countries and territories so
it's it's important to
to differentiate it it's a detail i felt
compelled to tell you because i think
your
taste is impeccable beautiful absolutely
all right it's time for damon and i to
deliberate so we're going to put you
guys on
mute so we can um speak honestly
and then we'll get right back to you
thank you we'll be right back okay
damon thoughts first of all fashion is
something that i
that i you know obviously i'm here
because of fashion
but when i asked tamara her
sales she had to think um that means
that
she's not that good with her numbers and
her data um
where you looked at the the cut board
they knew their sales they knew their
the the units they knew how many people
responded they knew how many stars they
had and
in a very short period of time they
showed um
they were only out i think a year right
and they showed a good amount of that
in a very short period of time in a
tough year yeah too
tough people were not spending a lot
i also think that they have an
interesting
angle and i would like to see them bring
their branding into their business a
little more because i wasn't totally
aware that you could do the custom
recipes and
customize it so i feel like they need to
bring that into their name too because
morning joy
company doesn't automatically ring
custom boards for me all right
so we've made our decision i think so
yeah let's bring them back please
okay both of you guys are just
incredible and there can only be one
winner so
um justin and jasmine you are today's
winner
and
you are going to go home with a feature
on our home page of our show's website
at the drewberrymart show.com
a consultation with award-winning pr
executive
susan mcgreno who launched martha
stewart's career
cuisinart virgin atlantic coach and ten
thousand dollars from bill.com
[Applause]
and tamara um you are not going home
empty-handed you're also gonna receive
a thousand dollars and i
am going to put my brain to think of how
to work with you you are one of the very
first companies
that i found personally out of the 75
000 entries i fell in love with you
i want to work with you with our flower
brands so this is the beginning
of something i would love to collaborate
with you